what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing our discussions on
green lantern at this point it's
actually really really cool this is why
I love the Green Lantern tie-in for
brightest a I think it's better than
like the actual main brightest day story
but basically what we do is we pick up
with the rise of parallax / God flash I
think it's actually really really cool
in terms of how this goes now initially
this picks up with a really with like a
few paramedics really it's kind of like
the aftermath it seems of what went on
with Atrocitus were you know that leader
of the Red Lantern Corps just kind of
went crazy and I killed a bunch of
people stuff like that but it is kind of
interesting because in the middle of all
this they're effectively involved in a
car wreck and where one of them seems to
die they're met by the arrival of the
Indigo tribe now remember when it comes
to the Green Lantern mythos the Indigo
tribe is one of several Lantern cores
that are out there and when it comes to
the various Lantern course one thing to
keep in mind is basically the phrase
ROYGBIV red orange yellow green blue
indigo violet that's the colors of the
various Lantern cores that are out there
the Indigo tribe is the most ambiguous
it's really the one that we don't know
that much about and they were designed
to be that way really for a long time it
really wouldn't be until I think after
like new 52 you that DC actually
explained the origins of the Indigo
tribe but they're also here with the
black hand now remember when it comes to
William hand he really had like his
biggest moment uh.well really had a lot
of big moments but he was one of those
characters that Geoff Johns kind of
brought back with regards to the Green
Lantern mythos and then started rolling
him over into like these small little
tidbit cameos he would show up here he
would show up there he'd be a villain
with a flat or I'm sorry of the Green
Lantern for a little while and then it
all basically culminated in the rise of
necron the head of the black Lantern's
basically the Lord of the Dead
quote-unquote or at least one of the
many aspects of death that exists out
there but the idea was that with William
hand because he was obsessed with death
he was kind of like the harbinger for
Necron meaning that he was the one that
basically started kind of expelling
these different rings and kind of
bringing the dead to life and sort of
laying the groundwork for Necron showing
up inside the main DC Universe but
following the events of blackest night
William hand found some measure of
redemption that's really what this is
and this says that he just becomes part
of the Indigo tribe now remember this is
the hunt for the various entities that
exists out there these physical
representations of the different aspects
of the emotional spectrum and so when it
comes to the Indigo tribe their entity
is proselyte Li's I think that's how you
pronounce it it's basically them kind of
showing up and telling this paramedic
who's really honest
death-bed you know on the moments when
he's gonna die and essentially say
you've been chosen to be the host for
proselyte the entity of the Indigo tribe
and so at this point we switch over to
the last video that we left off that
where we basically had flash show up and
confront Green Lantern and this is cool
because remember these two go way back I
mean they're they really have an
extremely lengthy history together and a
lot of that goes back to the events
before crisis on Infinite Earths in the
sense that you know they really kind of
like been teammates for quite some time
and so on and so forth they'd been on
the Justice League and they'd fought
together in various team-up issues and
so on and so forth but their friendship
goes back quite a way and the result is
that when it comes to Barry Allen really
showing up on the doorstep of Hal Jordan
the question is why are you working
alongside these other lanterns and I
remember when it comes to like the Green
Lantern Hal Jordan in terms of how he's
perceived by Barry Allen Barry Allen's
been absent from the DC landscape for
around 20 years and so all he recalls
about Hal Jordan is the old Hal Jordan
the way he used to be back when he was a
green lantern and it was just I'm the
good guy they're the bad guys and I
never work alongside them now where the
events of blackest night in the rise of
all these black Lantern's did require
the various superheroes to work
alongside all these other Lantern course
in the eyes of Barry Allen it's kind of
like hey look that was like a huge
universe shifting calamity like it was
the end it was the end times like the
end was nigh so we just kind of had to
do what we had to do in order to pull it
all off but at this point Barry Allen's
sort of stance is that blackest night is
over the war the Lantern course doesn't
really exist anymore and so as a result
like there should be no reason why
you're a lying yourself with these
various Lantern course especially when
you have the head of the Red Lanterns
Atrocitus killing like three busloads of
prisoners there's no reason for you to
be doing this now when the question is
asked why are you outline yourself with
these guys Hal Jordan actually comes
back with a pretty reasonable response
where you guys could bring in telepaths
where you guys could bring in various
people that have different abilities you
know impasse and so on and so forth and
where they could track down these
lantern entities at the end of the day
this is kind of in-house and that's
really sort of reminiscent of how DC
treats the Green Lantern for the most
part the Green Lantern is kept kind of
isolated from everything else that's
going on it ties in and it crosses over
but just because you see something in
Green Lantern doesn't mean it's an
absolute it's just so wildly popular or
at least it was at the time this was
being done that's a Green Lantern line
of stories we're just kind of do what
you want Geoff Johns and you know
won't really batten I so long as the
sales keep coming in and the stories
keep making you know keep making Bank
and so the result is that it's kind of
an entire book representation of that
concept in the sense that Green Lantern
who does kind of do whatever he wanted
to but it is interesting because the
idea of of how Jordan is saying look
these entities represent an incredible
level of power and we're keeping this
in-house because we're really the only
ones who are capable of tracking them
adequately and handing them over to
where they need to go and that makes
sense because there's no guarantee that
if Hal Jordan went to the Justice League
and I don't want to bring in like any of
the other Lantern Corps so I need your
help there's no guarantee that Justice
League wouldn't then turn around and say
okay we found parallax time to like put
them in a jar and keep him there forever
there's no guarantee they would be able
to handle it adequately because as far
as Hal Jordan is concerned the justice
league doesn't truly understand the
emotional spectrum they're not part and
parcel to the emotional spectrum they
don't know the ins and outs of how the
whole Lantern mythos works but how
Jordan does and so it makes sense that
with all the information that's held by
the various Lantern cores that are out
there Sinestro and the yellow answer
it's Atrocitus and the red lanterns it
makes sense that all that would be kept
in house that who are basically sort of
be isolated from the Justice League
themselves but it's not without merit
and it's not without note because Barry
Allen really kind of feels a measure of
betrayal here where it's kind of like
yeah but like were your friends but for
Hal Jordan it's a lot more personal than
that because while it is kind of kept
in-house the idea is that when it comes
to these entities those individuals who
are possessed by them are basically
being gripped with a level of power they
can't really begin to comprehend and
that's what Hal Jordan brings up he
basically says hey look you were
effectively dead or locked in the Speed
Force or what-have-you but you weren't
here when I was possessed by parallax
when I came home from space you know
from a mission and I found out Co City
had been destroyed that over the doorway
for parallax to seize hold of me for
fear of losing everybody else I became
this universe level threat I tried to
destroy everything in existence when it
comes to all those things but Hal
Jordans stance is you weren't here for
all that so you don't understand the
impact that being possessed by one of
these entities has
and so that's what's kind of cool about
this it's because Barry's admission
responses no I'm not going to like I'm
gonna stand here staunchly and we're
gonna find a way to work this out so
again it is kind of interesting now I
would argue in terms of like the way the
Barry Allen's done here it's almost kind
of like making up for lost time right
like trying to be more of a superhero
than he really needs to be it's kind of
like hey look just to show you how good
of a superhero I am we're gonna solve
this together what do you want to or not
but in the middle of all this Barry
basically finds out that is wallet was
stolen by Larfleeze by the orange
lantern of greed again this is why I
love Larfleeze it's those small little
moments here and there that make things
so amazing but again this is all kind of
taking place with the arrival of Nicole
which is to say the girl who's possessed
by the Blue Lantern entity and so with
them having this debate and having this
discussion they're met by the arrival of
the Indigo tribe now again this is kind
of cool because one of the things is hid
out here and one of the things that
seems to be indicated is that where you
have various Lantern of course out there
for the most part most of the Lantern
course kind of allow you to pick and
choose whether or not you want to wield
the ring for example if you're sitting
at home one day and a Green Lantern ring
pops up and it says you have the ability
to overcome great fear welcome to the
Green Lantern Corps you can say no and
the ring will search for somebody else
it'll say okay cool and it'll go out and
it'll find a different host due to the
fact that you rejected it when it comes
to the red lanterns it doesn't work that
way it's basically you know you have
great rage in your heart you belong to
the Red Lantern Corps and it will
forcefully try to bond itself to you one
of the things that's hit out when it
comes to this indigo tribe is they seem
very similar to the star sapphires in
the sense that the Star Sapphire Lantern
Corps basically sort of exists to
convert people forcefully the star
sapphires essentially go around and they
say this person has experienced great
love this person has experienced great
loss by extension of the love they felt
and so we are going to basically induct
them into the star sapphires whether
they want to be or not we've seen that
with like the the yellow lanterns for
example right you know I mean during the
whole Sinestro Corps war the star
sapphires grab members of the Sinestro
Corps and then encase them in star
sapphire crystal and try to convert them
for some ones didn't worked for some of
them that didn't when it comes to this
indigo tribe it almost seems to be very
similar to that in the sense that the
way the indication is given off in terms
of speculation from Saint Walker as well
as Nicole herself being possessed by the
you know the blue lantern entity is that
when it comes to William hand how Jordan
stands is just because of the fact that
you found some measure of redemption by
feeling compassion and being bonded with
a you know an indigo ring doesn't
exonerate you of all the past crimes
that you've committed where William Han
basically says yes but I've been born
again you know I've been baptized to the
fires of compassion and I've come out
anew the stance here is that well maybe
it's one of those things we're like
because of the fact that the blue
lantern says none of these people feel
hope maybe it's one of those were like
the the Indigo tribe ring basically just
takes over them it replaces all the
other emotions with nothing but
compassion and so in a sense if you were
to remove that ring what would they turn
into would they go back to their normal
cells and that's the question how Jordan
asks to end a you know indigo one if you
feel compassion by extension of this
ring and this ring effectively forces
you to feel compassion that if I were to
take you and I were to remove you from
the influence of the Indigo tribe what
would you become and so again that's the
whole idea of kind of feeding into the
nature in the you know the ambiguity of
the of the Indigo tribe and we'll find
out when it comes to her origin and how
it was as she came to be which is
actually pretty tragic but again it's
somewhat cool because where the groups
began coming to blows in the sense that
a fight is inevitably going to break out
just from all these differing opinions
and so on and so forth they're met by
the arrival of just this mysterious
being and this is just a cloaked guide
that's kind of been floating around ever
since the the conclusion of blackest
night we don't know where he's coming
from we don't know what his motivation
is all we know is that this guy's been
basically going around and capturing
various entities or whatever entities he
could and so he effectively shows up
here with the parallax entity and where
the initial response is that is supposed
to go for Hal Jordan what we end up
learning is that it's not instead the
parallax entity is going for the flash
Barry Allen which it possesses and Barry
Allen looks absolutely amazing but
basically it's all the powers of the
flash bolstered by all the energy and
all the evil of parallax himself it's
pretty sweet but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the robb cork if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like next week we will pick up
with parallax flash versus Hal Jordan
it's actually gonna be pretty awesome
and it's a pretty cool pretty epic
battle anyway guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]